[Musique]
football tombeur de saint malo ce
week-end le fc versailles 78 est promu
en national la troisième division
française
une grande première pour le club auteur
également d'un magnifique parcours en
coupe de france cette saison reportage
du sport automobile le départ du tour
auto édition 2022 était programmée mardi
dernier de plus le château de
rambouillet 250 bolide de collection
sont partis sur les routes pour
rejoindre andorre-la-vieille plus
d'informations à suivre jo-2000 24 ce
jeudi 28 avril deux événements sur les
jeux olympiques étaient organisées dans
les yvelines tony estanguet tête au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et hatim grande bretagne a signé un
partenariat saint germain les pour
s'installer dans la commune ce sera
notre module sport
[Musique]
énorme joie dé versailles et ce samedi
sur la pelouse de saint malo après
plusieurs mois en tête du championnat de
nationale 2 le fc versailles 78 validé
sa montée à l'échelon supérieur après sa
victoire en terre bretonne sur le score
de 2 à 1 dans le même temps chartres
seule équipe qui pouvait encore montée
s'est incliné face à caen donc en effet
plus que ferrer a pas que la coupe de
france en plus qui en plus des frères et
comptera plus que rempli pour les
versailles et cette montée en 3e
division espéré en début de saison est
une première historique pour le club à
cela il faut ajouter l'incroyable
parcours en coupe de france des joueurs
de la cité royale éliminé au stade des
demi-finales par nice 2 0 après un match
héroïque à l'extérieur une épopée qui a
conquis le public français et a rempli
la place du marché à versailles une
année de rêve je préfèrerais très peu de
hip hop avec le peu de m2 contre
une montée
pour valider définitivement le titre de
champion de nationale 2 les versaillais
devons prendre le meilleur sur plabennec
le samedi 14 mai à domicile dans leur
stade mob auront l'occasion de marquer
encore plus l'histoire de ce club né
d'une fusion en 1989
on débute ce tour des résultats sportifs
du week-end par les barrages aller de
fédérale 3 en rugby qualifié premiers de
leur poule le rc versailles s'est imposé
sur la pelouse du rc sablais club band
air des sables d'olonne le score 21 à 15
de son côté maisons laffitte aussi
qualifié pour ces éliminatoires n'a pas
su prendre le dessus sur l'équipe
d'issoudun ans entre val de loire
défaite 13 15 pour le mls gp mais rien
n'est fait puisque les matches retour
sont prévus le 8 mai prochain en
baseball la troisième journée de
première division avec les cougars de
montigny qui recevait les comètes de
victoire 8 0 puis 8,3 pour les premières
rencontres des inimités à domicile cette
année de succès net qui permet au club
de prendre la première place de la
division devant rang avec 5 victoires
pour une défaite les templiers n'y
arrive plus après un début de saison
canon l'équipe de foot us d'elancourt
peine à enchaîner les victoires 5
défaites lors des six derniers matches
dont la dernière à la maison ce samedi
face aux pionniers de touraine le score
7 à 30 au classement les templiers passe
derrière les dragons de paris et son
troisième sur quatre en poule b de la
deuxième division un mode horde balle à
présent il ne restait que trois journées
avant la fin du championnat où il devait
signer carrière s'est défait d'un
concurrent direct le club de bois
colombes 33 à 25 le hsbc est 7e sur 12
et juste devant plaisir les clés qui
conserve sa 6e place après son match nul
contre loudéac 33 partout en nationale 2
féminines victoire de montigny 31 24
face à dreux vernouillet pour l'avant
dernière journée au classement lésigny
montaigne pointe à la 7e position avant
un déplacement chez les derniers blanc
mesnil pour l'ultime rencontre de
l'année elles peuvent encore espérer
terminer sixième et on termine par du
taekwondo ce samedi se tenait le
championnat de france pour les
catégories minimes le club de le ttsq
ait compté six combattants parmi
lesquels quatre ont terminé sur le
podium de leur catégorie
nassim à la saq et sasha faire j'ai chez
les garçons décroché l'argent en moins
de 33 et 45 kg enfin de récompense
ultime lors pour asma mekkaoui chez les
filles en moins de 45 kg et pour antoine
le bars chez les garçons en moins de 30
kg des résultats qui portent le bilan de
l'école de taekwondo de trappes saison
2021 2022 a deux médailles nationales
dont quatorze titres de champion de
france
on va maintenant parler de la conférence
ligue de football un yvelinois joué la
semaine dernière en demi finale de la
compétition
son nom à matteo guendouzi le joueur
originaire de poissy formé au psg a
affronté le feyenoord rotterdam à
l'extérieur avec l'olympique de
marseille les viennois héros partie des
pays bas avec une défaite dans sa valise
lors de ce match aller l'om s'est
incliné 3 2 malgré l'implication de
matteo guendouzi sur le second but
marseillais le match retour est
programmé ce jeudi 5 mai au vélodrome de
marseille les lillois devrait être une
nouvelle fois titulaire
un autre rendez vous cette fois ci plus
locale à noter dans vos agendas le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines va accueillir cette semaine du
jeudi 5 au dimanche 8 mai l'open
international de tennis de table
handisport pour cette deuxième édition
près de 400 des meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux vont participer à l'événement
et tenteront de décrocher leur place
pour les championnats du monde à grenade
en espagne en novembre 2020
journée spéciale pour ces étudiants de
l'estaca aujourd'hui lucas etienne et
plusieurs membres de leur équipe col des
stickers sur leur première voiture de
rallye une grande étape dans leurs
projets automobiles ça fait plaisir
c'est un projet qui sa boutique mine de
rien on commence à voir
l'échéance arrivait donc donc c'est ça
va une nouvelle étape pour ce projet
imaginé pendant le premier confinement
mai 2021 lucas et qui prend forme depuis
la rentrée 2021 aux côtés d'étienne tous
deux novices dans ce secteur l'objectif
de ces deux passionnés de sport
automobile être la première équipe 100%
étudiante à prendre le départ d'un
rallye et à le terminer on avait
vraiment envie de remettre en avant le
sport automobile mais pas sur le domaine
du circuit le circuit c'est quelque
chose que on a l'occasion d'avoir un
petit peu partout et on avait envie de
partir sur rallye puisque
malheureusement le rallye c'est une
discipline qui est peu mis en avant dans
aujourd'hui dans le sport automobile
bien qu' on est des grands champions
comme un sébastien loeb sébastien ogier
aujourd'hui le projet mobilise une
trentaine de personnes de l'école
d'ingénieur il prépare cette voiture
achetée 12000 euros pour la rendre
compétitive comme voiture de base c'est
une 106 s16 donc elle est préparée donc
n 2 même top n2 donc en n2 c'est une
catégorie de rallions on prépare les
voitures mais le but c'est de rester sur
vraiment un petit budget donc elle est
assez préparés andrieu basiquement c'est
à dire on l'intérêt évident et il ya un
arceau
voilà le moteur est juste
reprogrammer un peu mais après tout le
reste ça reste d'origine après plusieurs
mois de travaux et des dizaines d'heures
passées chaque semaine sur la mécanique
le bolide est presque terminée les
sportifs pourront enfin prendre la route
après des mois d'entraînement sur
simulateur la voiture devrait participer
à sa première course début mai au rallye
du coeur de lion dans l'eure donc on a
des sièges qui sont assez spécifique
qu'il faut homologué environ tous les
trois quatre ans pour que cela soit
encore homologué ainsi que les harnais
c'est pareil à une homologation de 3 4
ans ensuite on a ce qui nous permet de
survivre au cas où s'il ya un arbre qui
traversent la route donc les arceaux
c'est à dire que c'est une cage en métal
en acier qui a s'est renforcé à ses
pairs au revoir on peut taper dedans
c'est complètement plein au total les
deux étudiants devraient prendre le
volant sur quatre courses avant la fin
de l'été leur objectif terminer les
courses dans un premier temps et
pourquoi pas viser un top 10 en fin de
saison
[Musique]
peut arriver à peu près à cette heure
c'est encore un moment une parenthèse
pour eux pour les passionnés qui est
extraordinaire ils se sont levés aux
aurores pour contempler chaque cylindre
et les passionnés d'automobiles étaient
au bord des routes ce mardi 26 avril en
amont du château de rambouillet où se
tenait le départ du prestigieux rendez
vous du tour auto 2022 que d'habitude ça
passe pas par par ce département et là
c'est c'est bien ça va rambouillet
rambouillet yvon morvan si l'historique
du sport automobile français français et
même internationale et puis
c'était un plaisir c'est une musique
un peu plus loin près du château
certains équipages de pilotes se prépare
est encore au départ de cette 31e
édition effectivement sur rennes au
compteur on est un peu fébrile à ce
matin
échangions avec d'autres pilotes nous
sommes fébriles on surveille les
températures de volée température
d'huile que ça fuit pas on va regarder
en dessous sans oublier bien sûr ton
profiter du monde mais un magasin de
jouets à ciel ouvert pour onze enfants
et puis le cadre s'y passe bien parce
que des voitures finalement quand on est
passionné on en voit très souvent mais
le lieu le lieu en rajoute un petit peu
de magie à tout simple en tout plus de
250 voitures de collection se suivront
lors d'un périple qui durera cinq jours
première étape on finit à la baule donc
sur le bord de mer
là c'est un rallye qui va se disputer
sur l'ouest de la france parce que de la
baule nous allons à limoges à près de
limoges à bordeaux de bordeaux à pau et
l'arrivée se fait à andorre donc on
attend tous avec impatience l'arrivée
parce que je pense que la montée là
d'andorre avec noé boli ça va être il
fallut ce qui me surprend à chaque fois
c'est toute l'émotion mort la déroute où
il ya énormément de monde le départ
s'est achevée en fin de matinée soit un
peu plus de trois heures pour laisser à
chaque bolide le soin de faire rugir son
moteur
comme tous les jours ou presque julien
vient s'entraîner dans sa salle de sport
située à vue en cours pendant une à deux
heures ce sportif de 26 ans transpirent
pour sculpter son corps son objectif
être performant dans le culturisme au
bodybuilding anglais un sport qu'il a
débuté à l'âge de 16 ans alors qu'il
faisait 60 kg en fait était à la base un
sport que je faisais vraiment injuste
pour le sculpter un corps me sentir bien
dans ma peau et avec le temps en fait
quand tu commences à prendre un petit
peu les habitudes quand tu commences à y
aller à des heures régulières tu
rencontres des gens les mêmes gens
régulièrement et de ce fait en fait ça
devient vraiment un endroit un petit
cocon où tu passes une heure deux heures
par jour et au final en fait avec le
temps battue continue à ath documenté à
découvrir un petit peu ce domaine là
après dix ans de pratique julien n'est
plus au stade de l'observation mais de
la compétition libinois participe à des
concours abatteurs espère un jour
obtenir sa carte professionnelle
pour atteindre cet objectif la tête d'un
mètre 77 pour cent kilos doit convaincre
sur scène un jury lors de ces rendez
vous ici dans sa catégorie les
observateurs évaluent le buste des
participants selon plusieurs critères
nous on est plus en fait homme de plage
donc c'est à dire on va avoir des
positions dites naturelles donc
évidemment là quand même un travail
spécifique de la contraction on essaie
d'être le plus relâchée possible et
effectivement d'avoir une prestance
d'une aisance sur scène ce qui est le
plus important d'avoir ce qu'on appelle
le posing et en fait on est jugé sur sa
sur la comme j'ai dit sur la symétrie
sur la masse musculaire mais également
sur ce qu'on va dégager sur scène c'est
un peu comme un ange envie de faire un
concours de miss france mais pour des
mecs me fais quoi pour faire découvrir
sa passion au plus grand nombre julien
sortir un film sur son parcours dans le
milieu du bodybuilding un documentaire
de 25 minutes projeté pour la première
fois à paris au mois de mars sur
l'objectif combattre les clichés sur
cette discipline moi aussi aujourd'hui à
mon petit niveau à ma petite échelle
j'essaye de combat ça justement faire
comprendre qu'on n'est pas tous ceux des
tout dans le dans les bras dans le
cerveau le but c'est vraiment de faire
comprendre que voilà on peut faire cette
discipline
mais quelqu'un de normal aussi d'avoir
un business à côté de faire sa vie et
d'être quelqu'un d'intelligent parce que
voilà il faut savoir que malgré tout
faut quand même être cadré et
intelligent pour faire ce sport-là
julien va maintenant continuer à
sculpter son corps sur cette année 2022
avant de reprendre la compétition au
premier semestre 2023 avec toujours cet
objectif en tête passer professionnel
[Musique]
ce jeudi 28 avril dans les yvelines on a
parlé à jeux olympiques deux événements
sont organisés dans la journée dans la
matinée un événement au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines et
dans l'après midi un autre assange
armand lui
[Musique]
ce matin au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'était la
tournée des sites tony estanguet le
président de paris 2024 étaient sur
place des grilles cannelle et lui a posé
quelques questions bonjour a tenu bon
jour triple champion d'europe triple
champion du monde triple champion
olympique vous connaissez justement
cette échéance olympique et vous
l'amenez maintenant en tant que
président du comité d'organisation de
paris 2024 vous visitez régulièrement
laissez vous étiez déjà venu ici sur ce
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
est là aujourd'hui c'est le début de la
tournée des sites olympiques c'est ça
pourquoi la démarré ici c'est un symbole
assez fort de commencer la tournée des
sites de paris du 24 ici au vélodrome
nationale vous savez le vélodrome
nationale c'est un peu la fierté du
sport français c'est l'un des fleurons
c'est un équipement incroyable qui allie
à la fois le sport de très haut niveau
mais aussi comme aujourd'hui des moments
d'initiation de pratique ouvert à tous
c'est un peu ça l'esprit de paris 2024
on veut que les athlètes français soient
dans les meilleures conditions on veut
qu'il gagne un maximum de médailles on a
envie que les françaises et les français
les soutiennent soit derrière eux et ya
rien de mieux que d'essayer un sport
pour être ensuite conquis et d'avoir
vraiment envie de soutenir ces athlètes
l'a donc aujourd'hui c'est une première
étape importante pour nous et on est
ravi d'être ici avec les plus grands
champions français en plus avec pour
objectif de visiter les lieux et vous
allez faire un petit baptême de cyclisme
sur piste il voulait peut-être déjà
testé à y paraît il paraît qu'ils m'ont
réservé cette surprise mais là ça serait
bien qu'ils aient pas les caméras s'il
vous plaît déplacement dans les yvelines
on le sait où il ya de nombreux sites
olympiques on a parlé de ce vélodrome
national de 50 ans nie aussi les
épreuves de goal de vtt de bmx qui se
dérouleront dans les yvelines
l'équitation également pourquoi cet
attrait pour les yvelines qu'est-ce qui
est en fait un département intéressant
pour organiser ces épreuves de paris
2024 que depuis le début de l' aventure
pareille 1024 les yvelines se sont
mobilisés ont montré leur enthousiasme
leur envie de faire partie de l'aventuré
on a tout de suite
réussi à avoir des bonnes connexions à
s'entendre parler le même langage à
avoir cette envie de d'un côté continuer
à accompagner le développement sportif
dans ce territoire qui aime le sport et
donc voilà du coup vu qu'ils sont
moteurs on est moteur et on fait plein
de projets ensemble et du coup ça
profite à la population comme comme
aujourd'hui par exemple avec peut-être
d'autres épreuves on parle du cyclisme
sur route aussi avec un tracé dans les
yvelines a été évoqué aussi un temps le
marathon pour tout ce qui pourrait
passer par un verset vous pourrez voir
de nouvelles épreuves dans les yvelines
qui ne sont pas encore annoncés
exactement en fait tout n'est pas encore
complètement finalisé et les yvelines
étant vraiment un territoire très moteur
ben il ya de grandes chances qu'on
continue à travailler avec les yvelines
parce qu'encore une fois je pense qu'on
partage le même adn et on a vraiment
envie de réussir ces jeux d'exception
2024 et notamment grâce aux images on
est à j moins 800 d'en parler de jeu
d'exception c'est qui aura déjà une
cérémonie d'ouverture unique jamais vu
qui sera en extérieur à l'extérieur d'un
stade sur la scène l'objectif de ces jo
quelle trace vous voulez laisser dans
l'histoire on a envie que sais je fasse
la fierté de notre pays c'est un moment
d'optimisme c'est un moment d'espoir
c'est un moment d'humanité ou si on va
accueillir le monde dans notre pays on
veut que les gens vivent des jeux
spectaculaires parce que c'est d'abord
des émotions qui doivent rester mais on
veut aussi que les jeux soient
participatif qui soit très ouvert qu on
ne résume pas à cette aventure à
quelques jours de compétition mais que
ce soit pendant plusieurs années la
possibilité de renforcer la place du
sport dans le quotidien des français
parce que voilà nous on pense que dans
ce pays si on investit un petit peu plus
dans le sport on va répondre aussi à des
enjeux de santé des gens les enjeux de
lien social les enjeux de l'éducation
des enjeux écologiques parce que voilà
pratiquer le vélo par exemple c'est
aussi un bon moyen de transport et donc
il ya plein de dangers aujourd'hui
autour de la pratique sportive et les
jeux olympiques et paralympiques doivent
être un levier justement une
contribution à notre société dernière
question tournée qui débute aujourd'hui
au vélodrome vous allez revenir dans les
yvelines prochainement je n'en doute pas
je n'en doute pas et ce sera toujours
avec beaucoup de plaisir parce que
encore une fois on n'est vraiment pas
loin et on est toujours très bien
accueillis ici c'est un territoire
romand sportif qui aime le sport et on a
plein de choses à faire ensemble
[Musique]
dans un peu plus de deux ans vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
sera remplie de 5000 spectateurs un
événement forcément très important pour
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et
[Musique]
ça se prépare très bien même de manière
très active et on sent que les jeux
approchent le travail avec le comité
d'organisation des jeux et quotidien
avec les équipes de saint quentin en
yvelines avec les villes et les
équipements qui sont sur notre
territoire on sent les jeux approchent
et c'est très satisfaisant et qu'est ce
qui reste à faire ici à 50 ans devine
alors on a la chance d'avoir des sites
existants bien sûr comme le golf
national et vélodrome nationale mais il
reste l'aménagement de la colline
d'elancourt où auront lieu les épreuves
de vtt et puis il reste à se préparer à
accueillir ce public qui va venir du
monde entier ça concerne donc des
problématiques de voirie et de gestion
des déchets de transport des spectateurs
mais tout ça sera prêt en temps et en
heure cette journée est importante pour
le projet olympique cette journée
importante et elle est symbolique pour
nous puisque la tournée des sites avait
été décalé à cause de la crise sanitaire
mais elle commence à saint quentin en
yvelines et c'est bien le symbole du
fait que nous sommes prêts à accueillir
les jeux
m
on va écouter maintenant la réaction de
michel callot le président de la
fédération française de cyclisme
[Musique]
c'est très important pour nous que ça
démarre par le cyclisme est ici plus
particulièrement à saint quentin par le
lieu où nos athlètes travaillent en
permanence à préparer les grandes
performances qu'on attend d'eux les jo
nous occupe à travers plein de dossiers
certains moins passionnant plus
administratif mais beaucoup au contraire
très très dynamisant soient liés bien
évidemment et en premier lieu à la
performance et ça se prépare longtemps
avant la performance olympique et puis
également liée à des sujets tels que
participer pleinement faire participer
nos équipes à l'organisation aux moments
clés qui sera celui de délivrer ce très
grand événement que sont les jeux
olympiques on va maintenant écoutez la
réaction d'un sportif qui devrait
participer à ces jeux olympiques de 2024
florent grimbosq évidemment j'ai cette
ambition d'être sûr présents sur ces
jeux olympiques est allé chercher encore
une plus belle médaille est-ce que tu
arrives déjà imaginer où c'est loin pour
toi c'est à la fois loin et à la fois
proche d'un côté parce que au niveau de
l'entraînement on est en plein dedans et
est proche parce que ben ça arrive
demain mais il ya encore beaucoup de
choses à travailler pour pouvoir aller
plus haut c'est la fin de cette tournée
des sites ici dans ce vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines maintenant
direction un saint germain en laye
cet après midi nous sommes à saint
germain en laye la ville va signer un
partenariat avec la timba grande
bretagne par accueillir la délégation
pendant les jeux olympiques de 2024
[Musique]
ce partenariat entre la team gb la ville
de saint jean les signifie que 90% de la
délégation viendra s'entraîner
régulièrement sur le site au stade
georges lefèvre au camp des loges à
partir de cet été jusqu'au début des jo
et leur rentrée au village olympique et
sportif viendront s'entraîner sur les
terrains de tennis de football de rugby
de hockey sur gazon de beach volley mais
également sur la future piste
d'athlétisme actuellement rénovation en
parallèle il pour s'entraîner dans la
forêt et se rendre à la piscine de la
ville
nous avons choisi saint germain en laye
pour deux principales raisons la
première est l'excellence et des
installations sportives elles sont tout
simplement fantastiques et la seconde et
l'accueil que nous avons reçu de la part
du maire et des autorités on est
vraiment ravis ils sont capables de
sécuriser le site pour l'équipe de
grande bretagne c'est probablement le
meilleur endroit le meilleur camp
d'entraînement que nous ayons eu et
on est sûr de nous et on est ravi d'être
ici aujourd'hui
pour la ville de saint germain les c'est
donc un très gros morceau la délégation
britannique termine régulièrement haut
du tableau final des médailles à tokyo
la team grande bretagne avait terminé
quatrième avec 65 médailles je suis
enchanté parce que c'est un moment
important de voir que les jeux commence
à rayonner en dehors de paris aussi et
ça c'était c'est une clé de la réussite
que toute la population française soit
concerné par les jeux et on voit bien
que la ville de saint germain qu'à une
villa royale voilà vient vient
d'accueillir la team usa by quatrième
haut rang
quand même et sur les derniers jeux
olympiques donc on voit que c'est quand
même pas anodin comme choix et vous avez
pu voir le complexe du camp des loges
que je connais bien c'est important
d'avoir les mêmes sports au même endroit
pour pour s'entraîner se préparer parce
que ça va permettre la cohésion d'équipé
et puis ici voilà c'est paisible il ya
une vraie qualité des infrastructures
donc je pense un très très bon choix de
la team 18
[Musique]
on va maintenant écouter à l'interview
d'arnaud péricard le maire de la commune
c'est notre interview express
[Applaudissements]
déjà c'est la concrétisation d'un
travail de séduction que nous avons
opéré depuis presque deux ans maintenant
pour avoir le plaisir de les accueillir
et puis c'est le début de cette aventure
olympique pour nous laisser germanois et
de s'inscrire dans cette dynamique que
constitue paris 2024 voilà en étant en
ile de france on est à quelques
kilomètres de paris c'est normal aussi
de d'avoir ou de s'associer à cette
aventure collective et si en plus on
peut le faire en mettant à disposition
nos infrastructures et je suis ravi en
tout cas que les anglais aient trouvé
ici à les anglais la team djiby et
trouver ici des infrastructures dignes
de leur capacité à obtenir beaucoup de
médailles c'est l'une des plus grandes
nations sportives au monde donc on est
très fiers et très honorés d accueillir
j'ai posé la question c'était
intéressant on a ici une communauté
anglo saxonne très forte donc j'ai je
posais la question de savoir si ça avait
été un élément important en fait non pas
du tout je crois que ce qui fait la
différence ce sont deux choses c'est la
qualité des infrastructures sportives ça
c'est là le premier élément et je crois
que le deuxième c'est la dimension
peut-être humaine que nous avons mis et
la qualité de l'accueil que nous avons
apportées voilà on les voulait on leur a
dit qu on les aimait et qu'on avait très
envie de les avoir ici et je crois que
de se sentir accueilli et de se sentir
un peu comme dans une famille ici c'est
ce qui va faire la différence
[Musique]
quasiment tout quelques disciplines en
raison des infrastructures ont lieu à
reims évidemment la voile n'aura pas
lieu à saint germain ce sera je pense à
marseille très très certainement et tout
le reste aura lieu ici mais au delà de
la pratique de ces disciplines sportives
c'est également tout un environnement et
tout un ensemble et c'est ça qui fait la
différence ce sont les golfs ce sont la
forêt c'est la possibilité d'aller se
baigner d'aller au cinéma d'être un
petit peu loin du tumulte parisien de
pouvoir profiter de paris si vous pouvez
si vous avez envie de vous détendre à
paris à quelques minutes en rer et puis
de revenir ici sur sa base arrière loin
à l'oxygène
[Musique]
sur cette journée du 28 avril des
sportifs sont également venus ici
assange envolé pour découvrira le site
je vous propose d'écouter cette sportive
qui était aux derniers jo c'est très
beau c'est très grand imposant on a tout
ce dont on a besoin on a des
installations incroyable des équipements
fantastique en fait ils ont tout fait
juste pour nous pour que tout soit
spéciale tout est d'un niveau de qualité
incroyable ici c'est la fin de ce module
sport spécial jeux olympiques de 2024
vous l'aurez compris cette journée était
particulièrement chargé ici dans les
yvelines en 2024 les jeux olympiques se
dérouleront du 26 juillet jusqu'au 11
août
[Musique]